I have dreams of the Queen wonders that  lived inside the hearts of love and  silent treatments of all the elderly  that I knew were once for what is your  name I seek the revelations of all of  that the holy toad to the unwise in the  dreams of cold and burrs in sunlight  that fade across lakes of black blood  and snakes that eat the loaves of  children from land trees in autumn what  is your name suffering is the wall of  ignorant men who never lacked to seek  the depth of their own hearts and only  see the wealth of a poor world suffering  to Flay its own back in knife wounds of  silver and brutal gladness where are you  from in the nightmare is a dream to the  nameless slug that wanders across  minefield  and the remains of deer and kings  through the plains  before anything was it arena for letting  go seconds the Zionists beating like  troublesome old noise the sexual  violence of lust is all the assurance  you will ever need to know the worth of  life